hey 42 here Jesus Christ Nelson Mandela
and Adolf Hitler
aside from being costumed guaranteed to
cause a stirrer to fancy dress party
these historic heavyweights all have
something in common they were all
leaders of such passion conviction and
Charisma that they could compel their
followers to do things both good and
evil they would otherwise never have
considered today's story of Madness mock
Messiahs and mass murder focuses on
someone who combined elements of all
three he was a captivating preacher with
the gift of the Gap a Firebrand
political leader who advocated radical
socialism and racial Harmony and the
Tyrant who used violence and death to
achieve his aims rising to prominence
during the era of peace and love he
eventually declared himself to be the
Messiah but instead turned out to be a
very naughty boy
after brainwashing his thousands of
followers into giving up their money and
freedom he eventually cost them their
lives by engineering what is to this day
the largest mass suicide in modern
history
this is the Twisted tale of Jim Jones a
self-styled prophet who makes
spirituality with criminality and
convinced his congregation he would give
them heaven on Earth but instead brought
about his own personal apocalypse
[Laughter]
now let's be honest most of us drink a
little more than we should and as I get
older bouncing back the next day isn't
as easy as it used to be but recently
I've been trying something new
introducing Zed biotics the world's
first genetically engineered probiotic
designed by PhD scientists who tackle
those rough mornings after drinking
here's the science behind it when you
drink alcohol gets converted into a
toxic byproduct in the gut it's this
byproduct not dehydration that's to
blame for your rough next day zbiotics
produces an enzyme to break down this
byproduct it's designed to work like
your liver but in your gut where you
need it the most just remember to drink
said biotics before drinking alcohol
drink responsibly and get a good night's
sleep to feel your best the next day I
recently tried dead by R6 before I went
out for an Italian meal with some
friends an event that I knew would
involve more than one bottle of wine I
drank a bottle of zbiotics before
consuming any alcohol and I was honest
amazed at how good I felt the next day
so go to zbiotics.com 42 and get 15 off
your first order using the Code 42 at
checkout you can also sign up for a
subscription using my code so you can be
prepared for any occasion zbiotics is
backed over 100 money back guarantee so
if you're unsatisfied for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember head to zbiotics.com 42
in user code 42-wit checkout for 15 off
a big thank you to zbiotics for
sponsoring this video Jones was born
into abject misery in rural Indiana in
May 1931.
his father was crippled in World War one
and struggled to find work and his
mother had all the maternal instincts of
a frog with amnesia
the family were evicted during the Great
Depression of the 30s relocating into
what was little more than a shack with
no indoor plumbing or electricity things
got so bad they were forced to forage
for food in nearby Fields Jim has left
to his own devices from a very young age
he frequently totaled through town naked
as an infant because there was no one
around to dress him at some point in his
childhood he was given a Bible by the
wife of a local pastor and it turned out
to be a lightning bolt moment for the
AFT nude infant
he studied the book ceaselessly and
began to attend multiple churches every
week getting baptized in several of them
religion and death fascinated Jones even
then he gave sermons to the local kids
and held mock funerals for roadkill he
also claimed to have special powers on
What occasion swearing blind he could
fly a boast that was proven alive
shortly afterwards when he jumped off a
roof and broke his arm
when he wasn't reading the Bible Jones
was engrossed in works by the likes of
Stalin Mao and Gandhi if it isn't
obvious already he was far from your
average kid instead of comic books and
Candy it was more communism and Cat
funerals when World War II broke out
Jones's new Nazi Fascination surprising
no one he commanded the neighborhood
children to Goose step in time with him
on pretend marches and beat them if they
refused between the roadkill funerals
and enforced fascism Jones had done
little to India himself to his school
friends and this pattern persisted into
puberty he went full briefcase wanker by
wearing his Sunday church clothes to
school regularly lecturing his fellow
students about the dangers of the 3DS
drinking dancing and the biggest D of
them all the devil
unless your idea of a good time was
linking arms and reading Psalms Jim
Jones was definitely not the guy to get
stuck with at a house party at College
he became increasingly politically
active and started attending Communist
Party meetings this was America in the
50s and the Red Scare was in full effect
merely being suspected of sympathizing
with the Communists could get you
blacklisted by the government
doing that Jones and his young wife
marcelyn actually were commies it's no
surprise they were regularly harassed by
the FBI
you could say they exhibited a few red
flags but these ideological intrusions
only serve to further radicalize the
young couple in the early 50s Jones
worked as a pastor at several churches
across Indianapolis
and in 1955 he founded the now Infamous
people's Temple it was supposed to be a
new religious movement that combined
Christianity with Communism
but as we'll soon Discover It rapidly
devolved into one of History's deadliest
doomsday cults to gain more followers in
those early years Jones organized Faith
healing conventions during which he will
call upon the big man upstairs to do a
spot of divine doctoring healing various
ailments amongst the attendees it worked
too not the healing obviously the
getting more followers bit
despite his earlier admiration for a
certain tiny mustache German Jones went
on to become an advocate for racial
Harmony and in 1960 the mayor of
Indianapolis made him director of the
local Human Rights Commission for all
the evil I was to come later in Jones's
life he actually did a lot of good in
that role this was still a time of Stark
division with one set of rules for the
city's white residence and another for
everyone else
Jones worked tirelessly to break down
those barriers desegregating everything
from the police department to the phone
company
Jim's desire for a more tolerant world
was evident in his personal life too
here marcelyn adopted six children of
various ethnicities to create what he
questionably called his rainbow family
but whilst outwardly he appeared to be a
paragon of virtue Jones was growing
increasingly paranoid in 1961 he told
his congregation he'd had visions that a
nuclear strike would soon destroy
Indianapolis
convinced America's end was nigh Jones
traveled to Brazil in 1962 to search for
a new home for the people's Temple he
settled in Rio de Janeiro working in the
city slums but here's Brazilian break
didn't last long Jones was unable to
find a suitable HQ for his fledgling
cult and back home in Indianapolis which
Against All Odds hadn't been wiped off
the map in a hail of nukes Jones's
fickle followers were drifting away
[Music]
diminished attendance brought Financial
issues and Jones was forced to sell
several of the people's Temple assets
including the actual Temple awkward in
1965 he left Indianapolis behind for
good moving his family and remaining
flock to Redwood Valley in California
once settled in the Golden State things
started to get very dark very quickly
Jones continued to preach that the
apocalypse was coming in all that crap
but now he also claimed to be the
Messiah sent to save the world despite
fancying himself a Divine Incarnation
his actions said otherwise he began
taking copious amounts of drugs and his
control over his remaining followers
grouped far more oppressive new members
of The People's Temple were forced to
transfer all of their assets to the
church and those who held day jobs gave
their entire salaries to their new God
Jones controlled every aspect of their
lives he set food rations approved
sexual partners and determined who could
marry
as for his own needs well he took what
he wanted even if what he wanted
happened to be married to another member
of the Temple
Jones set up an armed security unit to
enforce his will and those who went
against him were subjected to
increasingly severe punishments
including reduced food rations public
humiliation and physical violence
as horrifying as all this was Jones had
only just begun but no matter how
outrageously he behaved privately in
public his stardom continued to grow
this was the age of the hippie a time of
making love not war and as a smell of
just sticks floated across California
Jones's message of socialism and
equality struck a chord
by 1970 the people's Temple had opened a
branch in LA and moved their
headquarters to their flower power
capital of the West Coast San Francisco
membership grew steadily and Jones and
his disciples would brazenly seek new
recruits from rival churches involvement
in San Francisco politics allowed Jones
to befriend numerous City politicians
and he courted the Press using an
extensive network of contacts to
guarantee good publicity for him and his
cult I mean Church despite the pr
offensive word was beginning to guess
out that the people's Temple wasn't
quite the center of virtue it seemed as
rumors of exploitation and abuse began
to spread Jones decided it was probably
a good idea to move his flock far away
from the eyes of the media and beyond
the reach of the police his destination
of choice was of all places Guyana
the former British colony had a recently
installed socialist government and for
Jones it was the perfect place to
reshape the World In His Image
you might think convincing a bunch of
Americans to upsticks and relocate to
the Jungle to be ruled over by an
abusive megalomaniac would be a hard
sell
people do some pretty weird things when
they believe their Immortal soul is at
stake
so wolves hold around a thousand
faithful made the move cult-based
colonies don't build themselves you know
even if they are founded by the actual
bloody Messiah so Jones soon put his
loyal disciples to work toiling in the
fields 12 hours a day six days a week
as a reward for all this hard labor the
people of Jonestown were given food
rations that would have had your average
supermodel reaching for the snack draw
nobody was allowed to leave and anyone
who spoke out about the appalling
conditions will be sent to the medical
unit where they were dosed with
mind-altering drugs transforming them
into walking zombies Jones himself
continued to pop a plethora of Pills and
Potions all of which made his paranoia
saw to new heights he was convinced that
numerous enemies were out to destroy the
church so along with their back-breaking
manual labor and lack of food the
people's Temple congregation was
subjected to military-style drills
including simulated attacks on the
community
guards hidden in the forest would fire
on the commune whilst Jones chanted
nonsense over loudspeakers dotted around
the place whilst his terrified followers
took up weapons and stood ready to repel
these fictitious Invaders
by November of 1978 abuse in Jonestown
have become so widespread that the US
government center team led by California
Congressman Leah Ryan to investigate
the delegation included newspaper
reporters a TV crew and relatives of
some Jonestown inmates I mean residents
Jones took the intrusion in his stride
holding a small party for The Outsiders
however the facade of normality quickly
crumbled many residents have concluded
that Jones was not the Messiah after all
and upon realizing that he was just a
very naughty boy they saw the delegation
as an opportunity to escape but when
Jones's more fanatical followers got
wind of what was happening one of them
lost his [__] and tried to stab the
congressman unsurprisingly the
delegation decided it was time to get
the hell out of there taking 15
congregation members with them but after
hightailing it to a small airstrip of
females outside of Jonestown they were
intercepted by Jones's personal militia
armed men stormed the runway with all
guns blazing and by the time the bullets
had stopped flying Ryan and four of his
team were dead
horrific though this was far worse was
about to take place back in Jonestown
Jones knew that even by his own
outlandish standards this was it you
can't just gun down a politician and
expect to be left to play God in the
jungle there would be no quiet
relocation this time the U.S authorities
will come after him like a seagull after
a bag of chips so he took a drastic
measure something that's still hard to
hear about even today almost 50 years
later he rounded up his most trusted
lieutenants and had them prepare a huge
vat of the soft drink flavor Aid lacing
it with a cocktail of drugs Jones knew
he'd lost but if he was going down he
was going to take everyone else with him
just in case you're still on the fence
about what kind of a guy Jim Jones was I
mean you probably aren't but just in
case I can tell you he decreed that the
congregation's children should be the
first to drink the poison
Jones's own wife marcelyn stepped in at
this point in an attempt to stop the
madness but guards held her back as the
children began to die with their parents
watching on marcelyn managed to break
free but it was already too late
distraught she grabbed a cup of the
poison I was dead minutes later
in Jones's own words it was a
revolutionary suicide a protest against
the evils of the world for many members
of The People's Temple it wasn't even a
suicide let alone revolutionary
the few survivors claimed that most
people sat patiently waiting for their
turn to die but a small minority refused
to drink never one to take no for an
answer Jones had his goons pinned them
down and inject cyanide into their blood
streams
in the space of just 45 minutes a
staggering 909 people were dead 276
children amongst them
Jones was found with his followers a
bullet hole in his head whether he
committed suicide or was murdered by one
of his flock nobody knows for sure
either way the people's Temple was no
more
in the years since de Massacre there
have been many cult leaders who've
preyed on The Good Intentions and
misguided faith of their own followers
to line their pockets and fulfill their
own warped fantasies
but for sheer force of Personality size
of ambition and eventual scale of
Devastation few have come close to their
sunglasses wearing Second Coming that
was Reverend Jim Jones
and thank God for that
thanks for watching